passer le dernier Noël avec sa famille
c'est le souhait le plus cher dans le
blanc 76 ans cette semaine elle a appris
que son cancer du foie et c'est trop
avancé pour continuer les traitements en
octobre la chirurgie visant à lui
retirer une tumeur a été annulée à la
dernière minute alors qu'elle était en
route vers le bloc opératoire elle a été
placé sur une liste d'attente
prioritaire mais on ne l'a jamais
rappelé je me contente
d'avoir vu jusqu'à
à Neublans à bord de la situation avec
une certaine sérénité mais ça fait
Suzanne elle est furieuse elle accuse le
gouvernement de Jason Kenny d'être
responsable de l'engorgement du système
de santé albertin c'est lui qui a décidé
de ne pas accepter la quand les autres
provinces on peut venir et
cet été et le gouvernement albertin à
lever toutes les restrictions sanitaire
dans la province qui a mené à une
explosion 2K 2K 19 à l'automne selon le
ministère de la Santé au moins 15 miles
chirurgie ont été reporté pour laisser
des lits aux malades de la covid-19 lors
de la quatrième vague au total plus de
81000 chirurgie sont en attente
sur les patients selon leur part des
chirurgies à d'importantes conséquences
sur leur santé mentale et leur qualité
de vie de son côté à Neublans ne sais
pas combien de temps de plus la
chirurgie lui aurait permis de vivre
mais hélas sûr qu'elle n'a aucun regret
[Rires]
[Musique]
William Beaumont